csgo has once again hit a new Peak
despite being 11 years old this past
Sunday the game had more concurrent
players than it ever has before the
question on everyone's mind is why
from a tech perspective the game is
unimpressive the code is built on a
house of cards and the developers are
the absentee parents of the gaming
industry so why the hell is CS go more
popular now than it's ever been before
so over the weekend more people were
playing CS go at the same time than any
other point in the game's history the
peak was recorded on the 27th at about 9
A.M with 1 million three hundred and
fifty four thousand two hundred and
forty eight players beating out games
like Dota 2 and the previous record
holder Lost Ark absolutely wild and you
love to see it now for context its last
Peak was back in April of 2020 with only
about 40 000 fewer obviously that's not
a massive Gap but it's important to know
that the game dipped significantly after
that that Peak was right when the
pandemic started popping off and people
were stuck at home and they had nothing
better to do than pick up baking and tax
Shooters apparently but just like every
other Trend during that time csgo's
boost wasn't going to last forever so I
would say the dip was expected however
this is where it gets interesting in
August of last year the player base hit
1 million again and month after month
the game continued to grow and grow and
grow and well here we are now as much as
people have been remarking on the
achievement or reminiscing about the day
they first installed CS go it's also
opened a broader discussion about how a
decade-old game on a broken engine can
still be this successful and keep
growing but here's the thing there isn't
just one concrete answer to this bizarre
mystery so let's talk about it to start
let's look at the fundamental reasons
why CS go is so popular csgo is part of
a franchise and there are people like
myself most professional players and
many of you who've been playing it since
1.6 but at the same time there are those
who have started much much later and
since the core of the series has
remained the same it's allowed for the
game to span across generations of
players that history and Community
counts for something on top of that CS
go actually has something even more
important going for it it's a really
really good game it is crispy utterly
satisfying endlessly complex and its
mathematical approach to how the game
executes from tick to tick is
dangerously addictive and all that is
true even when you're spectating and I'm
not exaggerating when I say CS go is
responsible for so many of the
fundamentals within the FPS genre I'm
serious regardless of what type of game
is being made if it's an FPS CS go is at
the top of that brainstorming list and I
think the csgo Twitter account gave a
perfect response as to why this is
because it takes minutes to understand
and a lifetime to master and the more
you invest the greater your Returns the
feeling when everything comes together
never gets old whether it's a one tap a
perfect spray a new piece of util an ace
or a clutch it's Counter-Strike that
history and fulfilling gameplay no one
else has ever been able to recreate that
and it's why I think so many people keep
coming back or starting for the first
time now although simply uttering
Counter-Strike can feel sufficient I
think there are other less poetic
reasons for csgo's current success and
one of those biggest reasons is skins
it's no small secret that csgo's world
of Cosmetics is a bit of a phenomenon
and the in-game skin economy has its own
dedicated following but it's not just
about the novelty of opening cases to
try and get a gold CS go Skins are as
unique as fingerprints could potentially
cost millions of dollars and certain
items carry immense history all those
aspects have created a market that
doesn't exist in any other game hell to
a lot of people out there the Skins are
just as important as the game itself it
also helps that certain regions and
countries like China are massive players
in the skin economy so they consistently
boost that player base whenever a new
case or operation is dropped and it just
so happens that csgo released its first
case in over seven months yeah that's
how [__] starved we are by Gaben that
getting a single damn case after over
half a year of radio silence creates the
largest Peak the game has ever seen we
are down tremendously bad bit bitterness
aside it is a new case and since it's
the first one we got in a long time I
could see it being the reason a ton of
people came back next to that valve also
added a new map to the active duty pool
not too long ago and so far Anubis has
been an absolute hit seriously the grip
that map has on me should be studied
anyway forget the valve praise because I
actually think there's one more reason
for csgo's recent success one that at
first glance might seem a bit odd
because I think it's valorant that's
right it might sound crazy but I think
the so-called CS go killer not only save
the game but help it reach New Heights
altogether valent released around the
time of Cs Go's last Peak but as I
mentioned since then csgo has seen its
ups and downs for the first time since
maybe the release of Siege CS go had
actual competition and a lot of people
went over to try Riot's game and I'm
sure plenty of people stayed but here's
the thing I don't think they never came
back don't get me wrong valorin is a
great game in its own right and I think
CS go having direct competition is
objectively a good thing that being said
I just think CS is the tighter
experience that can't be replaced
especially if it was your first taste of
attack FPS on top of that valoran
brought a ton of new people into the
attack FPS genre and I think sooner or
later those people were going to want to
try CS go maybe the new case the new map
and the fact that the Esports the best
it's been in a long time made it the
perfect reason for people to try it the
final question is will this BCS go as
high as Peak and regardless of the
answer to that question what does its
future look like listen it's one of my
all-time favorite games and definitely
my favorite competitive game and I think
it's going to go down as the most
important shooter of all time but as I
said at the start CS go is a flawed game
and more than any of its technical
issues its biggest problem is valve's
lack of communication sure they made a
game so goddamn good that they don't
even have to make content for it and
honestly respect but how much longer is
that going to last for if I'm at least
partially right and people are coming
back to see us or trying it for the
first time because of a new map and
Anime skins how long are they going to
stay when they realize that's all
they're getting for months now with all
that being said I don't want to read it
on the parade too much because this
overall is [__] sick CS go is more
popular than it's ever been in its
entire history and that's honestly
heartwarming so let me pass the
questions off to you guys why do you
love CS go so much and why do you keep
coming back time and time again anyway
that's all I got love you guys see you
in the next one
favorite maps in the history of
Counter-Strike d-rats number one FY ice
World FY pool day another good one surf
Egypt assault CS Assault is one of the
greatest Mouse of all time it's one of
the worst maps of all time like from an
actual like balance perspective but also
one of the greatest Vibes all around
Cobble bring back Cobble bring back
d-rats why are there no d-rad servers
anymore